[Music]
all right we've been talking about the
projected win totals courtesy of the
sports books in Las Vegas and here's
what we're gonna do now Chris this is
our draft for the day and we have all
the projected win totals available we
are going to draft the teams that we
believe will exceed most likely to
exceed the wind totals that are
projected by the sports books in Las
Vegas this is the time in the draft
where I let you pick the heads or tails
on the coin toss because we've dispensed
with rock-paper-scissors unless we're
doing it in person you will pick tails
it will be tails and you will win go
ahead let's hope that's correct go ahead
Kristin tails never fails and it
literally never fails just so it's not
obvious everyone so on a day when there
isn't an obvious first pick that is the
day that I prevail that's right I'm
gonna I am gonna begin and there are
plenty that I can choose from and I know
what some of yours are from our prior
discussions in the program but frankly
I've forgotten them otherwise I would be
able to steal some of yours I am gonna
begin with one that is glaring to me
become boy there's a lot yeah I'm gonna
go with one that we talked about earlier
I believe wait which one wasn't now let
me just start with the Seahawks at eight
and a half I believe in the Seahawks for
the second straight year
I think the Seahawks will win at least
nine games I think the Seahawks will be
back in the postseason again I think
that Russell Wilson will continue to
prove he's one of the best quarterbacks
in the NFL he'll be motivated to do so
because I don't think he's gonna get a
new contract before the start of the
season and I think just quietly this
Seahawks going about their business
going about their business I think the
Rams are dipping a little bit and I
think the opening is there for the
Seahawks to get to double-digit wins in
2019 yeah okay I mean it's not a
horrible pick hey certainly the Seattle
Seahawks we know there are this is where
I'll throw like the caveat or at least a
curveball to you I do think the San
Francisco 49ers are gonna be a team to
watch out for this year I think the
third year with Shanahan Lynch this is
the year we're gonna see a jump in their
football team
and yes the Rams can they replicate what
they've done the last two years I don't
know but they're not gonna fall off very
far there so they still got some work
left in that division certainly what I
want to say 49ers the 49ers ear at 8:00
take the 49ers wise guy I'll pick my
team's first okay you worried about your
draft I'll worry about my draft okay you
just draw you're saying how much better
what do you nine is it gonna be maybe I
will maybe I'll go there in a second but
you know what I'm gonna start off with
I'm gonna go with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers all right that's where I'm
starting with the sixth win the sixth
win projected Tampa Bay Buccaneers I
look at it and go man Bruce Arians and
his he's worth a win or two justin is
just with himself okay what he'll do for
Jameis Winston you know the offense as
far as his ability to create big plays
scheme wise with Mike Mike Evans and
Godwin and some of the other talented
guys on that offensive side of the ball
Peyton barbers are very good running
back and I like some of the things they
got on defense still yeah I mean they
still have jpp they got vite of via who
was a top-10 pick last year at a
Washington who didn't get to play cuz he
kind of dealt with an injury all year
long of course you know what's the damn
middle the defensive tackles name I'm
blanking on his name in the middle you
know they have some Young's
Gerald McCoy very much yes I was
blanking on his name he's only played
for 15 years I know it's it's
disrespectful that I thought but I look
at the Tampa Bay Buccaneers as being
that team at least that beats the
projected win total and I really think
they're gonna be in the playoff
conversation come December yeah look I
don't want to get too caught up in my
respect and admiration for Bruce Arians
to believe that he's gonna be able to
fix Jameis Winston I know they they want
to think they can fix him I thought it
was intriguing last week Jason Light the
Buccaneers GM acknowledged that my
theory that maybe you know his reach
exceeds his grasp or his graphics I his
reach right he tries to do more than he
can do that they they get that and I
don't know that you can coach that out
of him and there's gonna be moments
where he tries to do something he
physically is incapable of doing and
that could cause it all to fall apart
however I do think that that division is
not as good as it's been and it does
give them an opening to get know
six so that's not a bad one from you
although I just I think it could all
fall apart for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
alright I am going to now pick hmm I had
one and then I lost and all the Jaguars
at eight how would the Jaguars at only
eight they have Nick Foles the Superbowl
50 to MVP they're a team that was in the
AFC Championship Game
in 2017 yes they were five and eleven
last year but I think with the changes
they've made I think that Nick Foles and
a new attitude and kind of a reset to
2017 that makes it very easy for this
team to get north of eight wins now does
that mean they're gonna get ten eleven
twelve no but I think nine is doable for
a Jaguars team that needs to settle down
and I think Nick Foles can settle this
team down unlike any other quarterback
that was available to them this
offseason I think it was a great move I
think it was a smart move and I think
the Jaguars are gonna be on the right
side of 500 this year yeah I'm not gonna
disagree with you there Mike I mean I
certainly think the Jacksonville Jaguars
are one of those teams I say watch out
for they're gonna rebound in a big time
way I mean of course Nick Foles at the
quarterback positions huge the defense
is special that's what we really can't
forget I mean that's really at the end
of the day when you talk about all three
levels of that Jacksonville defense and
you go it's still one of the best front
fours in football it's still one of the
best linebacking core is in football and
the secondary I don't think we can argue
it's the best in football especially
with which I believe to have the two top
corners in the game on the same team in
Ramsey and AJ boy yeah I'd go there one
and two in the whole NFL so I'm with you
there I think if they stay healthy
Jacksonville is gonna be a real pain in
the butt in the AFC okay I'm gonna go
with the team I already talked about I'm
going with the San Francisco 49ers in
the fighting Kyle
he might be my friend but you know the
last two years I've told a lot of people
pump the brakes I don't think they're
gonna be that good I think this is the
year where they make some make some
noise I really do
first of all Jerick McKinnon he should
be back in the fold at running back
healthy signed Tevin Coleman who's one
of the more explosive running backs in
football from the Atlanta Falcons free
agent Jimmy Garoppolo being back they
got one of the best tight ends and
football is is their offensive line is
one of the best in football you know
their defense was much improved last
year certainly have a very good
defensive line but then you get Kwan
Alexander at middle linebacker that was
a great signing and then trade for D
Ford and though you know let's not
forget they're sitting pretty at the
number two pick two they're gonna get a
difference-maker there and it could cost
but possibly be Nick BOCES so I'm
projecting a little bit but I just go
the 49ers year three of the Shanahan
Lynch regime guys gonna be healthy and I
think they've made the proper roster
improvements where I'd go this is the
year they make a jump and I'm not saying
they get in the playoffs but I think
they're gonna be flirting in that nine
and seven ten and six range when all
said and done one thing that I have
realized while looking at the projected
win Turtles yeah it would be easier to
identify the teams that I think are
gonna fall short because there are
several that I'm looking at saying oh
god that team is not getting to that
amount here's one that I am willing to
say will go over if and and you know I
am basing this in part on the study that
the number of quarterbacks playing full
16 game seasons is on the rise and the
NFL is doing a better job of keeping
quarterbacks healthy and if this
quarterback does a better job of keeping
himself healthy and I'm talking about
Carson Wentz the Eagles easily soar past
nine and a half wins for 2019 I think
they're a team that we are not taking
seriously enough we locked into a
narrative that they're not very good
last year meanwhile they got to the
final eight and almost beat the Saints
to get to the NFC Championship I think
the Eagles are gonna be a team to watch
out for in 2019 if Carson Wentz can stay
healthy yeah that was a good pick I'm
not gonna disagree with there that's
where I was gonna go next with the
Philadelphia Eagles certainly I mean
you know get to Sean Jackson get Malik
Jackson on the defensive side of the
ball
I mean they've done some nice things in
free agency re-signing Brandon Graham
and Ronald Darby you know getting Vinny
Curry back in the fold and yeah I think
a little bit with what's happened this
offseason with Nick Foles situation him
leaving town and what you said about
Carson Wentz and all that kind of gonna
refocus the team a little bit certainly
I think will refocus Carson Wentz so not
a bad pick by you there I can't really
push back very hard against that all
right this is where it gets tough it
really does I mean holy crap is it hard
to pick these pick this last team here
you just stole my pick - I am going to
go hey you always got to have six ready
now you're always gonna have six down to
two teams I'm kind of shuffling back
between the bills and the Falcons okay
those are the two teams I'm pushing with
there and going oh I don't know where I
want to go there I think I'm gonna go
with the Buffalo Bills okay I'm picking
the Buffalo Bills as my third pick
because the Falcons it's still a tough
division and I don't know if I trust it
all the way yet so I'm going with
Buffalo one because I like what I've
seen from Josh Allen - I like Brian day
balls and offensive coordinator they get
cold Beasley and John Brown as receivers
to help out that off and sign Mitch
Morse at Center who's one of the best
centers in all of football you know
they're improving their football team
and then on the defensive side of the
ball they were already one of the best
defenses in all of football
they got a guy like Kevin Johnson from
the Houston Texans who was a first-round
pick they signed him I just look at the
Buffalo Bills and go they're a team to
watch out for in my opinion and I think
they will eclipse six wins I think they
will not say in their playoffs but I
think they're gonna be at least seven to
nine eight and eight and in the convo in
December what would you have put their
number at for projected wins if they had
pulled off the Antonio Brown trip oh
that's I guess I guess I would give that
off I would give that a full win more
right maybe seven seven and a half maybe
somewhere in that range
everything thanks seven and a half
yeah some thirds I I kind of agree with
his six is too low for them maybe I'd go
all the way to eight if they had had a
Antonio Brown cuz I still think they
should be at seven as it is ya know I
you know and again you know I just think
with the way they play football on the
defensive side of the ball I mean this
is the number two defense in all of a
football last year and they had weeks
again let's not forget where I mean they
had no quarterback play where Josh Allen
was hurt and how out with the elbow I
mean they signed uh you know Anderson
off the gun off the golf tee off the
golf course to come in and play a game
five days later so you know they're a
team with Zay Jones a receiver the
Robert Thomas kid who came on with a
speedster down the field now they got a
tight end to go with it got Tyler Croft
and free agency with those receivers I
mentioned I just think they're a team
that's certainly trending upwards and
you know I have a love affair with the
head coach Sean McDermott I think he's
one of the best go with someone you
gotta remember their name yeah my picks
Seattle at eight and a half I say over
Jacksonville and eight and eagles at
nine and a half obviously all of these
are over that's the purpose of the draft
Sims has Tampa Bay at six
the 49ers at eight and the bills at six
quick break moment return
the Raiders are fully committed to their
quarterback but they are still working
out a couple of the big-name incoming
quarterbacks will break that all down
next when P it's a lot of continues
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports